depuis que l'homme est homme et la femme
femme
les ex existe je vous déclare ex mari ex
femme vous pouvez vous embrasser ton
père et moi on a décidé de se séparer
bah il était temps que toi ça ça doit
être les services secrets annoncé mon ex
c'est pire quand on sait pas on se doit
le respect mutuel
on se pique grands pas je peux dire
quelque chose non combien en sinon je
n'ose ex ont laissé des traces plus ou
moins profondes dans nos vies puis vous
connaissez je suis non joly vous êtes
très jolie un souvenir de jean claude
blanc on avait dit qu'on fixe et pas les
clientes ta copine lacaune
je t'explique et il est dense intérieur
sans filtre les ex on les oublie pas ils
font partie de nos vies je l'aimais
tellement tu ta femme tu as faim ah oui
et c'est normal comme si c'était avant
tout le monde s'en fout on y lit la
ferment motors donc c'est un peu la
prime à l'ancienneté
souvent on regrette qu est ce que tu
ressens pour moi à toi
d'autres fois on retrouve son ex jeudi
dans tous les cas il est question
d'amour
au sommet on s'aime on s'aimera
c'est le compte le présent mon père je
me confesse que vous avez tous à vouloir
au couteau
mon père mais rosalie je crois que ses
besoins
une bonne petite confession on a commis
l'erreur toi et moi c'est de garder pour
soi des choses qu'on avait du respect
des jeux je pense sincèrement que tu
devrais faire un petit fou position au
niveau du cul
[Musique]